will you
ever stop making action movies oh yeah i
think so
i'm 68 and a half 69 this year
yeah there's a couple in the pipeline
and i think that'll probably be it
liam neeson is gonna stop making action
movies well yeah unless i'm on the
zimmer frame or something you know
no walker needed for liam in the
marksman in theaters tomorrow
he proves he can kick butt at any age i
mean i keep fit but i'm not a gym rat
i power walk i use a rowing machine
kettlebells liam's rowing machine slash
kettlebell
bod puts in the work in his 18th action
flick since 2008's taken he and his
young co-star
outrun a mexican cartel who's your
grandson
no his mother asked me to look after him
she must have had a lot of faith in you
did it at all make you wanna be getting
close to having grandkids yourself i
know you have your two boys
no why not i'm always saying to my kids
if you're thinking about getting married
wait until you're at least 35
women get their together
by their 26 27 28 years of age
we as guys have not a clue who we are
until we're at least 35. i just need a
little time to sort things out
plenty of fan casting rumors right now i
don't know if you've heard this one but
you played zeus years ago release the
kraken
and everybody wants you to play zeus in
wonder woman three if that happens are
you up for it
yeah i guess so sure i mean very
flattered i wasn't aware
that the ancient greek gods appeared in
wonder woman
zeus is her dad oh no really i'll call
my age